[Musique]
donc atteint
c'est l'uniforme qu'il en fit chaque
matin celui des chauffeurs de taxis de
la capitale indienne une routine que
rajesh kumar suit depuis cinq ans une
journée de travail de 12 heures qui
commence toujours par un rapide
nettoyage du véhicule
pour avoir une bonne note il faut que la
voiture brille sinon les clients vont se
plaindre
car à new delhi la concurrence est rude
la mégapole compterait 400 milles
chauffeur de vtc passant par les plates
formes numériques comme celle ci diplômé
en informatique
rajesh a quitté son ancien emploi en
2017 séduits par les promesses de cette
start up américaine gagner plus d'argent
plus rapidement mais son rêve d'être
financièrement indépendant tourne
rapidement au cauchemar
j'ai vraiment le sentiment de m'être
fait avoir quand j'ai rejoint hubert on
nous promettait monts et merveilles et
qu'on allait être rémunérés jusqu'à 1300
euros par mois je suis loin du compte si
j'arrive à gagner 400 euros c'est déjà
un miracle
car pour séduire un marché indien
gigantesque la plateforme numérique qui
l'utilisent propose aux clients des
tarifs parmi les moins chers au monde
le prix minimum fixé pour une course à
new delhi et d'un euro à peine de ses
revenus rajesh doit ensuite déduire les
frais à sa charge et rembourser le prêt
contracté pour acheter sa voiture sans
compter la commission prélevée par
l'application jusqu'à 30% difficile pour
ce père de deux enfants de subvenir aux
besoins de sa famille à la fin du mois
déjà tous les matins je dois faire le
plein et le litre d'essence et la
maintenance du véhicule sont de plus en
plus cher je vis avec le peu qu'il me
reste pour acheter de la nourriture et
payer les études de mes enfants
une armée de précaires
c'est ce que cache le succès de
l'économie à la tâche en inde hubert au
laso matausch weegee yourban compagnie
le pays compte 1 800 applications de ce
type en moins de dix ans ces startups en
majorité indienne ont popularisé les
services de livraison de transport ou de
soins à domicile
pour des millions d'indiens ces
plateformes sont vus comme la promesse
de sortir de la pauvreté et d'échapper
au chômage dont le taux 8% 2021 n'a
jamais été aussi élevé depuis trois
décennies
c'est le cas de shu même singh 23 ans
devenu coursier après avoir perdu son
emploi pendant la pandémie
voilà j'ai accepté la commande j'ai à
peine 30 secondes à partir du moment où
je reçois le signal
une fois la course accepté chouba ma 40
minutes pour mener à bien la livraison
une course contre la montre s'engage
dans la pollution la chaleur et les
embouteillages sont comptés les ruelles
labyrinthiques de la capitale indienne
allô monsieur je suis devant votre
domicile
subban travaille 12 heures par jour six
jours sur sept pour un salaire d'environ
dix mille roupies par mois soit 120
euros il se sent à la merci des
plateformes des restaurants et des
clients
nous sommes leurs esclaves la politique
de la plate forme et que le client soit
toujours satisfait s'il ne l'est pas
notre note va baisser nous risquons des
pénalités et notre salaire peut donc
diminué il s'en fiche qu'il y ait des
embouteillages que la route soit
mauvaise que le plat est mal voyager car
il était mal protégés ou impactés et si
un client annule la commande car il est
mécontent le montant total est déduit de
mon salaire en inde l'économie à la
tâche n'est pas un phénomène nouveau
80% de l'économie du pays est informel
et des dizaines de millions d'indiens
sont payés à la journée selon cet expert
ces plateformes numériques aggrave cette
situation en l'absence de régulation
les travailleurs n'ont aucun statut ni
salarié ni auto entrepreneurs et ne
bénéficient d'aucune protection
toutes les plateformes numériques profil
du chômage là où elle s'installe mais en
inde elles ne font que renforcer le
caractère informel de l'économie et de
l'emploi il n'y a aucune protection
sociale aucun contrat aucune fiche de
paie aucune sécurité d'emploi ni
protection en cas d'accident du travail
et dénoncer ses conditions de travail
n'est pas sans conséquence si massing et
esthéticiennes il y encore quelques mois
elle proposait ses services via une
application de soins à domicile
jusqu'à une nouvelle hausse de la
commission prélevée par la plateforme
ces mois-là anvers il tente de me sortir
de la manifestation
pendant des semaines avec d'autres
travailleuses elles protestent devant le
siège de la compagnie résultat si my
poursuivis en justice
accusé de manifesté illégalement
les représentants de la compagnie ont
menacé les manifestantes certaines ont
été convoqués au commissariat
moi je me suis retrouvé banni de la
plate forme du jour au lendemain au
chômage après avoir travaillé pour eux
pendant quatre ans sans nous il ne
serait jamais devenu cette grande
entreprise et c'est comme ça qu'il nous
remercie
récemment la cour suprême indienne a
demandé au gouvernement la mise en place
d'un système de protection sociale pour
les travailleurs des plates formes
numériques selon une étude américaine la
gui l'économie pourrait générer jusqu'à
90 millions de nouveaux emplois à long
terme en main